[Music]
another kind of weather a more
traditional way to think about weather
is what the air is doing on planets that
have atmospheres and moon doesn't have
an atmosphere so we don't think about
moon whether Mars has an atmosphere
Jupiter has an atmosphere Saturn Uranus
Neptune a couple of moons have
atmospheres so so when you study those
you see interesting patterns you see
storms you see Eddie's which are Eddie's
are tiny little spiral patterns of air
that might be their version of a tornado
and so I think you can only really
deeply understand weather on earth once
you study the weather on other planets a
planet that rotates faster than Earth
rotates less fast when it has higher
gravity lesser gravity and you can see
the full range of how weather takes
shape in the full spectrum of planets
that are out there and then you find out
where earth fits and you say oh that's
why that's that way because this is what
happens in that extreme and that's what
happens in the other extreme so that's
really what when I think of space
weather that's what I I'd like to
reflect on tornadoes are way more fun
than snowstorms if you're just watching
weather phenomenon tornadoes or or any
any cyclone just to think about the
energy it contains and what it's doing
with that energy what in the weather
system was the precursor conditions to
that storm way more fascinating to study
than just snowflakes coming out of this
guy
[Music]
[Music]